inciso de encuentra en la distancia
total que recorrió en la particular
desde el tiempo de igual a cero al
tiempo de igual a 1 así que recordemos
no nos piden el desplazamiento total ojo
nos piden la distancia total y es que si
algo se mueve no sea supongamos que algo
se mueve a la derecha así una unidad y
después se mueve hacia arriba una unidad
bueno en este caso tienen una distancia
de 2 es más y si después se regresa al
punto original entonces cuanto sería
esta distancia sería la raíz de 2 pero
ten cuidado porque si pensamos en
desplazamiento el desplazamiento total
de esta particular sería 0 porque
regresamos al punto inicial mientras que
su distancia total sería uno más uno más
la raíz cuadrada de dos así que como
encuentro la distancia total en
escenario de aquí bueno la distancia
total va a ser lo mismo que la rapidez
por el tiempo es decir si quieres saber
la distancia total en este intervalo lo
que tenemos que hacer es tomarnos la
rapidez que recuerda la rapidez es la
magnitud del vector velocidad la
magnitud del vector velocidad
esta es la rapidez déjame ponerlo así
rapidez
y si a esto lo multiplicamos por un
pequeño cambio en el tiempo por un
pequeño cambio en el tiempo entonces en
este momento estoy obteniendo un pequeño
cambio en la distancia un cambio
infinitesimalmente pequeño en la
distancia es decir un cambio muy pequeño
en la rapidez por un cambio muy pequeño
en el tiempo nos da un pequeño cambio en
la distancia y si ahora no queremos
tomar los pequeños cambios sino todos
los cambios desde el tiempo te iguala 0
hasta el tiempo de igual a 1 entonces lo
que vamos a hacer es tomarnos la
integral definida desde 0 hasta 1 de
esta expresión que tengo aquí es decir
la suma de todos estos pequeños cambios
en el tiempo en este caso desde el
tiempo está igual a 0 hasta el tiempo de
igual a 1 nos va a dar la distancia
total que nosotros buscamos esta será la
expresión de la distancia total y bueno
cuánto será esto bueno pues esto
va a ser igual a la integral de 0 a 1 de
la rapidez pero la rapidez ya la
teníamos en el ejercicio pasado recuerda
aquí en el inciso se nos preguntaba en
la rapidez y la rapidez es esta
expresión que tengo aquí es decir es la
raíz cuadrada la raíz cuadrada de y
bueno primero me voy a tomar a la
componente x del vector velocidad que
sabemos que es coseno de t cuadrado y
esto lo vamos a elevar al cuadrado es
decir vamos a elevar al cuadrado el
cambio en x con respecto al tiempo es
esto de aquí al cuadrado ya esto le
vamos a sumar y ahora vamos a aplicarnos
en el cambio en ye con respecto al
tiempo es decir la componente del vector
velocidad esto elevado al cuadrado y me
quedaría
elevado a la 0.5 y todo esto elevado al
cuadrado bien observa que esta es la
rapidez como una función del tiempo del
lujo ya la tenemos aquí ya esto habrá
que multiplicarlo por de gea y después
vamos a integrar todo esto para obtener
nuestra distancia total y para nuestra
suerte podemos usar la calculadora en
esta parte del examen a penn para
evaluar esta integral que tengo aquí así
que si traigo por acá a mi calculadora
la voy a poner justo aquí entonces me
voy a ir a más y después al número 9 que
es la integral definida de quién bueno
quiero en la integral definida de la
raíz cuadrada así que déjenme poner por
aquí mi raíz cuadrada de y bueno primero
voy a abrir el paréntesis para poner el
coseno de t cuadrada elevado al cuadrado
así que lo voy a poner aquí el coseno
esto elevado al cuadrado y después
cierro paréntesis y a este coche no
desde cuadrada lo elevó al cuadrado muy
bien ya esto le voy a sumar y ahora voy
a poner esta expresión de kim pero esta
expresión de aquí recuerda que en el
vídeo pasado vimos que era lo mismo que
en elevado a la t lo tengo justo aquí en
elevado al 0.5 teme al cuadrado es lo
mismo que en elevado al 0.5 por dos por
t lo cual es a la tele entonces voy a
poner en lugar de todo esto a la t tú
puedes poner todo esto pero voy a poner
más fácil a la t entonces voy a poner en
elevado a la t ok
cierro paréntesis y después voy a cerrar
el paréntesis de esta raíz cuadrada así
que voy a cerrar este paréntesis y bueno
déjame ver si lo estoy haciendo bien
este paréntesis se cierra aquí este de
aquí y 0 este paréntesis y ahora
recuerda que hay que poner la variable
bajo en la cual estamos integrando que
estén y después ponen los límites de
integración del límite inferior es 0 y
mi límite superior es 1 y ahora si
cerramos paréntesis y me voy a tomar la
integral definida de todo esto que está
aquí y ahora si le pongo enter se va a
tardar un poco y ya está
me dan que toda esta integral toma el
valor aproximado de 1.59 5 así que vamos
a escribirlo todo esto me da un valor
aproximado de 1.59
5 y está de lujo porque esta es la
distancia total que recorrió la
particular desde el tiempo te iguala 0
al tiempo te iguala 1 y bueno todo esto
está genial porque observa cuántos
incisos pudimos resolver con esta
pregunta inicial con solamente estos
datos que nos daban en el problema
original